here's the deal what's the point of
being a father if you know you'll fail
what's the point of doing anything
really what's the point of even sticking
around this is about the guy I guess I
killed tried to kill himself after I had
talked about him he was found at a
bathtub by his podcast buddies who
resuscitated him with the news at the ad
read I did last week was it did in fact
move the numbers so people are checking
it out so tune in every week to another
Bachelor podcast on iTunes YouTube at
Spotify remember everyone escapism is
the only thing that matters right now
there is nothing you can do to prevent
us from annihilation the only other
thing you can do is find ways to cope so
listen to another Bachelor podcast or
their spin-off show recapping Bravo's
hit series below-deck another below deck
podcast and also available where you get
your podcasts I mean III you know go
check it out I wish these guys did bet I
mean listen I mean you know yeah here's
what it is here's what it really is no
one respects you like that's what it is
well if you're a producer of a podcast
unless you're Jamie Vernon no one
respects you that's what it is it's just
what if you're replaceable you're I mean
I it's not I'm glad you do your job well
but it's it's not really it's just not a
thing like it's not my plumber is
part-time does my taxes too yeah it's
kind of like that you know I like
specialization where someone specializes
in something like if someone came up to
me goes you in a nice restaurant they go
you know who's cooking in the back Bruce
Springsteen I go why why is Bruce
Springsteen making our dinner but maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe would be great
it's been known in America here's your
kids do Yeah right I don't know
so these podcast producers right now
they get a chatty yeah they're very
chatty because they're they're sick of
being behind the the scenes well look so
because they think it's a big mistake
they think it's a big mistake
that they sit behind the scenes and
other people don't they all think it's a
cruel twist of fate and it's just that
they they should be theof on should be
producing your podcast that's what these
guys thinking when they go when they put
their head on the pillow in their manic
Minds they think that they are the
reason that Co is funny they think
they're doing it this is the result of
Occupy Wall Street
your job is going to be done by a I last
week so I'm glad you're so his reality
and this is a sweet kids and I don't
want anyone to think this is Meg I'm not
trying to be negative no I'm just trying
to be I appreciate because I would if
Lissy if you if you listen The Bachelor
watch another bachelor podcast so I need
to listen to The Bachelor because I
should enjoy the but just listen to the
[ __ ] podcast okay and I listen I'm
not trying to be a dick to anybody
because I love everyone I think
everyone's worthy of at least life you
know what I mean at least be here on
earth but like you know just make it
good like I hope it's a great podcast
and I'm sure it's not that bad right I'm
sure it's not that bad
but like that's what it is it's like
you're not gonna get famous by having
like you know a [ __ ] you know like I
don't know like do show less for a
certain amount of time then it's over
it's a fun podcast right so it's just
funny it's nice that they're also doing
below-deck so they're expanding they're
doing like a bunch of different things
you know I'm not trying to [ __ ] on what
they're doing by the way I'm not sure to
[ __ ] on what they're doing I respect
that people are out there hustling but
like just like don't just just I think
you get it you know just understand what
it is so don't be offended when I like
there's people that listen to the ad
that are offended like one of the guys
got a Fed first of all if doing that if
you're offended by anything I say why
are you doing anything
immediately sure don't be offended by
what I say
you're a friend about what I say if
you're further we want to say don't do
the ad I don't care it means nothing to
me less than I can't explain to you how
little this means to me to do
legitimately less than nothing um but
don't be offended by because I hope
people do genuinely check out your show
but this isn't real it's not real and so
I just want you when you go to bed every
night to know that it isn't it's not a
real thing you're doing and I don't mean
the show isn't real I don't mean the
show isn't real
your show is real I mean your life your
your existence on planet Earth isn't
real it's not real you're an avatar
you're an idea you're an avatar you're a
shadow that's reflected off a lake in
the moonlight but that being said I
would check out the show I'm gonna
appear on their below-deck podcast
potentially not now after this ad but so
listen it's called another bachelor
podcast and their spin-off show the
spin-off show they're spinning off
spinning off if you like but if you like
this you'll love that
this Pinto show is called below-deck
it's another below-deck podcast they do
a podcast about like fidget spinners
maybe yeah they're they're done now so
that's it I don't want to listen again I
love everybody I hope everybody loves me
it's all in good fun it's all a good
humor Royall kidding around don't be
offended be like to hear that anyone's
offended by anything I said in an ad
read is is absurd to me and it's it's
really crazy cuz I called the kid who
has been doing these reads and he wasn't
offended but he's like yeah one of our
the guys was like a little offended and
it's like it's like well what do you
think it is is it my dream you're doing
a Bachelor recap podcast and you're
advertising on another podcast and
you're offended about what the guy said
like what do you think you're doing what
world are you living in where it's
there's none of its real what we're
doing isn't real it's not real if my
[ __ ] show which is great and listened
to by people is it real if Hollywood is
it real if the country isn't written out
of it's real it's a simulation if all of
it isn't real how in God's name is your
bachelor recap podcast real how are you
getting upset about it
think to yourself that your metadata on
a [ __ ] aliens iPhone dummy oh that's
all I'm saying it's it's it's it's more
metaphysical I'm not going at you you
simpleton I'm not going at you what I'm
saying is that it's it's it's you know
just enjoy just enjoy that you're in a
unique period in five years you're not
gonna be making a trillion dollar it's
over soon you're at the end of this now
it's coming to an end
podcasting is gonna end soon I don't
know when it is but it's going to end so
just enjoy what it is
while it is don't get angry about what I
say none of it matters it's all it's all
fun none of its real it's not real the
below does spin-off podcasts where you
sit down earthward starts what are we to
do which episode did we cover last week
and did we cover three or four shut up
just enjoy it because one day you're
gonna be dead and no one is gonna care
do you know what I mean
no one is gonna care about your death
nobody no one will remember you no one
will speak kindly of you no one will
value any of your achievements or
accomplishments you'll just be know how
I know
that because when I went to is to
Spokane comedy club there were four hot
dogs on the menu and they were the
karlon the prior the rivers or whatever
and these are the greatest comics that
ever lived and they just became hot dogs
okay and you guys are almost as talented
as Pryor okay but not but like you're
like almost there
so just don't be upset that's what I'm
saying it's a fun ad you can keep
running them if you want I hope people
check out the podcast if you don't want
to run them that's fine too you know if
I ever see in person obviously will will
never speak I'm kidding again like we
said about my bachelor podcast I don't
like it it makes my wife and kids
then I'm feeding off my bachelor podcast
when this guy's gonna [ __ ] on it you
know what happened Ellen did that
five-second we got a bachelor podcast oh
we advertised on the show you know what
this fat [ __ ] did he's [ __ ] on it
trying to make it like it was like
stupidest son can you believe it
yeah no I didn't say nothing about that
below-deck podcast she kind of likes
that one but he didn't like her but so
just again calm down check it out it's
another it's another bachelor podcast
and another below-deck podcast and who
were the three guys again it's Nick
Dylan and Pat Nick Dylan and Pat I think
Dylan was the one who got mad
I don't think Pat got mad he's the older
guy and nicked him get me but I think
Dylan got mad I don't know who is Dylan
to look it up roof find them find him
it's not Dylan roof Dylan roof has a
Wikipedia so let's apologize to Dylan
who's it I'm looking it up isn't he the
guy that worked at Corolla with them
it's a baseball oh boy well didn't we
meet him when we went to Corolla isn't
it that guy Dylan Pete Wren is that
I have no idea edit his name out okay
y'all yeah yeah because god only knows
what all pit bull yeah is it's Dylan Ren
but I'll bleep that out yeah Dylan I
mean they can look it up it's on the
podcast bio but you don't want to make
it easy
Dylan weirdest address we're kidding
around doing you know it's a joke it's
you doing a bachelor podcast can I see
him is there another photo of them it's
him
there's no photos of him at all I mean
this is Twitter that's it I think right
here yeah he's a Jew huh that guy's a
real Jew guys a real big Jew face it's
what it is
you could call me a Mick face that guy's
got a Jew [ __ ] face you see that for
coming from a mile away
you see that we're 16 minutes into this
Reid we're trying to have fun
Dylan Dylan the only chance again [ __ ]
listeners is this [ __ ] high do you
want crack it gives you [ __ ] about your
bachelor party yes unless we make it
[ __ ] interesting okay you know you're
not cleaning Adam Carolla's toilets
because you're a genius
there are a lot of bachelor because it's
another bachelor podcast are you
assuming the plethora of these yeah
there's there's ones that are doing very
good I'll tell you how good they're
doing they don't they don't want a
20-minute harangue but I'm serious I I
support art and artists and that's what
we do here so if you can be if you can
enjoy that you can be playful and have
fun with it
but if you're gonna be serious about it
let's just not do it and I don't care
about the money and I don't care about
anything and I clearly don't I've pissed
awful you know and said a lot crazier
[ __ ] about a lot
more people who can help me out then
this [ __ ] nonsense so let's just come
to [ __ ] reality and understand that
we're having a lot of fun with this you
know what I mean this is this is what
we're trying to do we're trying to get
you listeners we're trying to get me
listeners still don't be angry this
isn't like it's not the Manhattan
Project
it's a feud now though you're starting a
podcast for use your a feud with the
another batch of podcast guys oh boy
here we go
I mean he's not a feud III listen I like
Nick he's a he's a he's you know he's a
person on earth that you know I wouldn't
I don't want him to like die I don't
want anyone to die some people yeah so
that's where we're at with this we want
you to check out another Bachelor
podcast with Dylan the older guy cuz I
nailed them when I did the first three
that kind of nailed them one guy you
know and then there's the other guy this
Dylan's got it takes it way too
seriously and then Nick just probably
has fun with it and Dylan's just
probably like taking away to see and
it's just like but gonna wreak havoc
joke yeah exactly